[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road mm my
name is Caleb I will be your driver on
this journey today what I wanted to do
was take a look at some of my games from
a tournament that happened actually in
2017 so a couple years ago now but it's
relevant because this weekend actually
is the bill right the bill right seat
was open and so I'm planning to play
this year and so I wanted to take a look
at how it went for me back in 2017 it
was actually one of the best tournaments
I think I've ever had and took down some
big names but so let's take a look here
I just wanted to start off at round one
I was playing international master
Michael Brooks and let's see how it went
I started off with one d4 this was back
before my my English days against
Jonathan France this is what I've been
playing for a long time now he responded
d6 I went Knight of three g6 c4 Bishop
g7 v4 Bishop g4 and by this point I was
already kind of confused
so not really where you want to be
against an international master and
round one generally you hope to have
some idea of what's going on past move
four but you know it's the way it goes
sometimes moves for as is as far as you
make it but you know I at least had some
idea of what he was doing right you had
seen I'd seen something like this before
at least in casual games but so what is
the point of this move what do you think
what is black saying right away with
Bishop g4
yeah that's right he's giving up some
light score control by threatening to
take this night giving up his
LightSquared bishop in exchange for
control over these dark squares
specifically d4 and d5 so you know I
kind of knew what to expect moving
forward you know moves like knight c6
moves like 'if I've you know and those
are pretty much the main two moves that
that would attack the d4 square but you
know I was basically I knew he wanted to
put a knight on this square so my next
few moves were kind of aimed at
preparing for this for this to come
forward so first I played Bishop b2
simply breaking the pin so now you know
I'm saying okay if you want to control
the d4 square you're gonna have to at
least give me this bishop you're not
gonna be able to just pin me I he goes
ahead and does play this knight c6 move
I play Bishop e3 defending the dark
squares e5 d5 so I have to give up
control now because there's no way for
me to really control the square another
time yes so I mean it's why black played
this way it works as a plan he takes
away my dark squared defender for his
light squared Bishop and he gets control
of this square so I'm I could take on e5
but that doesn't really look it's good
to me so I just played a d5 just
intuitively this is what I thought would
be a the best way to continue so he does
go ahead and capture on f3 here I
recapture and he gets control over this
square so this was the whole point of
the way he had played in the opening as
he gets to have this nice knight on d4
but you know it didn't come for free
right eve kind of spent some time
bringing this bishop out and trading it
off for the night and he did have to
kind of stunt his own bishop in order to
control this square he stuck his Bishop
kind of behind this pawn so what you
often do when you're not sure of the
opening is just try to play natural
moves what you fall back on usually is
those standard opening principles so I
didn't do anything too crazy I just
developed my knight
he played 97 and okay I guess now I did
go a little bit a little bit nuts
so uh what do you think is going on here
for both sides what are some some ideas
so a pretty general question but let's
start with what are what are the plans
what does blacks plan going to be
yeah he's a couple things you can choose
from right one big thing is the class at
Kings Indian attack with a you know this
f5 and f4
following up with g5 g4 and you know
stuff like this stuff we've seen before
so if I were to Castle you know maybe
I'd be walking into something like this
although it doesn't look quite as normal
as it usually does right because now I
have this extra option to take here and
after maybe putting some pressure here
something like c5 and now I can take
here and all of a sudden your standard
attack isn't really looking so standard
anymore right you don't have any of
these normal ideas that black usually
has because you know I just get to open
the e-file and things this would be kind
of radically different from the normal
Kings Indian plans so I'm not so sure
that this is what black wants to go for
I'm also not sure that Knight b5 is
actually the best way to take advantage
here but so this idea of you know taking
on d4 and taking on f5 is going to be
kind of awkward for black to deal with
if he goes for this plan so maybe black
wants to try something else here
any other ideas if you can't plan on the
kingside where do you play a queen site
that's right
so what are some some moves we might be
expecting here on this half of the board
what was that yeah so c5 is probably how
black wants to start so let's put it on
the board and then maybe an a6 b5 pawn
break could be something he's trying
here something like this could be
Black's plan just expanding on the on
the Queen side and you know trying to
find play over there but you know that's
not to discount this f5 idea because
this is also something to keep in mind
and so now we have an idea of you know
some plans black might be doing what can
white try and do here
yeah you can try playing on the
queenside with something like b4 but
you've got to be kind of prepared for it
because you know a5 might come maybe
takes takes and all of a sudden you well
you can't play before right away because
of this tactic right and so you might
have to prepare before somehow and if
you play a three like suddenly a5 or
even c5 let's start with a 5 and I won't
seem to be rookie 1 and now the c5 move
might come in well I can kind of try and
lock it down on the Queen side as well
so in the game I was thinking about all
this and you know I was also kind of
concerned with this f5 move you know as
well even though I kind of discounted it
analysis here so what do you think I
went for because I didn't go for the
standard Queen side stuff because it
looked a little bit too too slow to me
what do we think
it's worth noting this line where you
know I can't actually just like went
upon here cuz if takes takes islets say
92 there's actually c5 here and this
change of structure isn't actually so
favorable for me because I give up it's
kind of important to e5 square and I'm
opening up the scope of this Bishop but
that's certainly an idea to keep in mind
for later but okay
so what I did I wanted to play on the
Kings side I wanted to stop this f5 move
and now that he got rid of this
LightSquared Bishop I wanted to try and
make use of my own bishops here trying
to you know look at some Kings side
squares so I haven't yet committed to
castling so what I did was actually play
g4 locking down this f5 square and you
know trying to push forward on on this
side of the board and you know by this
point I was well out of you know known
theory that I I knew but this is
actually how most people have played
this position you know I'm in good
company here I think shear I've actually
played a game like this where you want
g4 and so yeah I mean it turns out it's
a pretty decent move so yeah this is an
important idea to keep in mind in these
structures I guess especially with the
slight squared bishop off the board you
can kind of start expanding over here on
the Kings side is white sometimes so
okay it continued with c5 walking in
that night I continued with h4 just
following my plan and after a six Bishop
e2 and this idea is of course just you
know giving this pawn some mobility as
well as no longer tying down this Queen
right someday I might want to play Queen
d2 and attack this Bishop and I'd rather
not lose a bishop on f3 when I do you do
that so Bishop e2 I'm actually still
following I think quite a few games here
just one okay but you know this guy knew
what he was doing probably mr. Lupo Mir
but okay so there should be two York PA
Queen d2 and this is actually quite
pleasant for white you know if you ask
the engine it likes advancing right away
a bit more but after Queen d2 you know
things are still good so let's see how
continued with Queen a5 and now of
course what is black threatening with
Queen a5
sneaky threat sneaky threat he made here
he's not a Moulton not B 5 B 5
eventually but he's actually threatening
to win material if I don't do something
about it for example in the game I
played h5 and this allows black to do
something here
yeah might be three is just a fork so
pretty weird tactic that I just missed
just miss this tactic in the game so you
know not a great start by missed it I
mean I intentionally sacrificed the
exchange after eight takes be Queen a
one Bishop d1 you know it's it's obvious
after Rick g8 that this Queen is just
gonna be out of play and White has
plenty of compensation but uh you know
of course white is simply much better if
I play something like Bishop d1 here
just keeping an eye on this square and
then I can continue on with my plan kind
of at my leisure and yet black white is
actually doing quite well here again I
would like to point out but okay so in
the game I missed it I played aged 593
takes takes I should do one and now rook
g8 which this Rick g8 was actually
pretty strange it's a kind of gives me a
chance to get back into the game
what are some other things maybe that
would have been a bit better for for
black here
it's kind of tough to find a move right
King d7 don't know how I feel about that
moves so much I might play aged six and
this is forcing Bishop f8 and now I got
to be pretty careful of this guy got to
be pretty careful here so what I thought
he would do is the simplest which is
just retreat the Queen back you know he
took his material time to get back into
the game and enter true to his queen in
the game he played this route g8 move
here probably well he did it to give his
ass Bishop to h8 square but probably I
should still play this h6 move instead I
took and he captured back so he vacated
the H file so I wanted to make use of it
and now I let's see there's only really
one way here for white to try and kind
of stay in the game try and claim some
compensation it's pretty interesting so
what I wanted to do was take advantage
of the fact that his Queen was kind of
stuck right so how can I try and trap
this Queen
what can I try and do to trap this clean
so someone in the YouTube chat suggested
castles butts uh this just allows them
to retreat right and now I've just
opened the H filing taking my work off
of it which it doesn't make too much
sense not what we want to be doing yes
so 94 is the most natural way to do it
right you just block off this retreat
square and then the Queen can't escape
but there's kind of one problem with
this move right so if you play 94 maybe
black plays b5 right so b5 and suddenly
you just have to move back right there's
no way to really stop it
so this is what led me to the correct
move which I actually found in the game
so I need to have some answer to the
move b5 before I play nine a4 so how can
i you know change the position and such
such a way that I can kind of stop this
b5 idea from cutting me off
okay so Queenie - he might still
actually just try and get this b5 move
in oh so well let's see Queenie to
actually just queen a5 and then night
i-4 is a bit too late because he's
already escaped
so yeah the YouTube chat has some
interesting ideas the YouTube chat is
suggesting b4 I'm not so sure what the
point is so b4 pawn takes so pawn takes
I assume Knight a 4 is the idea well no
so the bishop defends the night right we
slowed out this Bishop here so before
pawn takes knight a 4 B 5 still though B
5 after that and then what can you do
what can you do in that position so b4
pawn takes Knight a 4 B 5 it's still
kind of tough right
hello Jacob Sanders hello new YouTube
chats
any ideas b4 pawn takes Knight f4 b5
seemingly forcing our Knight to move
away again yeah alright YouTube's got it
YouTube's got it so the idea is this
rook is undefended so we play this b4
move for one kind of opening up our
Bishop and secondly allowing after pawn
takes Knight a for our Queen to come
into the game so if b5 we can actually
just take on b4 here and now this work
is kind of unfortunately misplaced and
this Queen is going to stay a little bit
stuck for four longer so I actually
managed to find this in the game
thankfully and so after after this
happens this is the one that we followed
you continued with a5 forcing the Queen
back seaming or not forcing the Queen
back the Queen can't come back because
now we have Queen takes a four so
forcing the Queen to come into d6
actually and after rook d8 I played
Queen b6 so this is now a sacrifice of
my knight which he accepts but I go
ahead and simply castle trying to stay
calm make use of the fact that this
Queen is still stuck and after Queen a2
now all of a sudden it's it's time to
you know really figure out what we can
do here so in the game I'm kind of
terrified I'm down a full rook against
you know an international master but I
had the feeling I should be winning
somehow so what do you guys think do you
think White has a chance to win or well
it's certainly oh there's chances but do
you think white should be winning what
do you think Black has some way to
escape here let's try and calculate it
out
what can we do
so I mean how is like a 13-2 escape
let's start with that house black trying
to get out
you put the Queen unhe two for a reason
right what's this one's not so hard how
does how does he escape yeah you takes
this pawn on c4 takes the free pawn so I
wanted to do something about it so I
started with Queen b5 King f8 and now
now what what to do
see so I start with Queen B 5 and now
people are suggesting maybe a Bishop c5
move b3 for some reason which I'm not
sure I entirely understand so the
problem with b3 is it's giving him all
of these squares to run to as well we
kind of want to keep those locked off
so yes someone has suggested a winning
move which is Queen takes a five so
Queen takes a five hits this rook the
rook might move somewhere like c8 and
now how can we how can we break through
it's the winning idea here
Wow people suggesting every move Under
the Sun some more legal than others but
okay so what do you think
it's a tough game it's a tough position
so yeah a lot of people suggesting d6
now which is I think I think it's a
winning try simply pushing the pawn to
victory sometimes it works and for
example one nice line let's say we see
knight c6 probably just d7 right would
come to mind and then if something like
you know just rook d8 blockading the
pawn what do we have here
to checkmates one is correct ones
incorrect
they're both checkmate but one is far
better than the other one
all right that's the wrong checkmate but
it is still checkmate so you get some
points yeah well because this one is
much funnier you know whatever you can
sack your queen you are legally required
to but so okay so this would have been a
nice end of the game so yeah after d6
you know it's actually quite difficult
to find what you should do here with
black probably I think you can give some
material back maybe after Queen takes c4
and things here are still not so
complicated now so easy at all but you
know I do like White's after d7 I think
is it's just going to be winning yeah
for example I think you might have to
play like queen d3 just to stop this
from being checkmate and then already if
nothing else I can take here and yeah
let's say for example just take here and
now I've regained my rook and your King
is going to be quite weak unless you you
know figure it out right away and most
of this line I think is correct the end
part might be nonsense cuz in a position
like this you know the computers are are
far ahead of us but okay so Queen takes
a5 would have been winning in the game I
played another move people were
suggesting which was Bishop takes a four
simply adding some pressure here because
you know I miss this d6 ideas quite a
good one but so I missed it I think also
winning here is d6 immediately because
of course you can't capture this guy
because of a check and you know this
isn't really what you want out of life
but okay I missed all the wins I played
Bishop takes a four and now already
black is kind of coming back into the
game after rook AJ believe it or not
Rick AJ is the way for black to get back
into the game which I didn't believe in
the game but so my opponent believed it
and apparently it's true so that's
always unfortunate so now I wanted to
really lock up this Queen really wanted
to lock her up
so I played Bishop C
five Bishop f6 and Bishop e3 so finally
finally finally I've achieved what I
want I'm going to kill the Queen
the Bishop takes beef with Bishop to b3
but you know unfortunately the his point
with her head shake was revealed which I
entirely missed in the game he can just
activate his rook in the most you know
non-conventional way I've ever seen
rip g8 to h8 to h3 guarding the b3
squared so I can't trap the the Queen
yet and you know no need to fear though
right I can play it f3 here maybe but
maybe there's a problem with this
problem with this way of playing so it's
not so obvious right away but while I'm
busy trapping his queen he's gonna be
doing some stuff of his own yeah I mean
you can check on g3 but that's not so
dangerous right I can just maybe block
or not block but you know move my king
okay he could sacrifice his rook and
this was something that concerned me in
the game a little bit this might have
been the reason I didn't play this line
but actually you know it's not so clear
right that's Bishop still hanging you
can take here I can take here let's look
at this check follow down the line and I
think maybe I can escape over to the
Queen side hopefully
but yeah it's kind of unclear that's a
good point actually here there's
actually one way only one way for black
to win the game yeah black can win here
despite having his Queens stuck all the
way on a two
I wouldn't be surprised if you guys
don't find this because it's beyond my
scope as well but okay the idea is he
activates his remaining pieces also in
some pretty unconventional ways
yeah this night stuck this bishop has
some ways into the game but so it's not
gonna help immediately
so what pieces do does that does that
leave so king g7 winning the game I
would play Bishop III you know foolishly
trying to win the Queen but after a rook
h8 let's see what's going on here this
ship takes a to rook h1 check rook h2
check and if I try to save the rook
check and mate
so you know I maybe try it a little bit
harder run away this way still might run
into this check King d3 rook takes f1
and now all of a sudden I've devoted all
of my pieces to winning this Queen and
checkmate is threatened and I don't know
how to stop it right how do you stop it
I don't think you I don't think you
really can and so this would be one of
the most of third ways to lose to lose a
chess game I think I didn't quite go
down that way in the game but you know I
think it's worth mentioning because I've
never seen such an attack with two rooks
and a bishop you know succeed with you
know a queen and two bishops like
reasonably close and the king with all
this open space but that would have been
tough so obviously I saw all that
decided against f3 and played Queen b6
instead just attacking his rook and so
now he plays again the winning King g7
daring me to capture this rook which is
a dare I accepted because if I don't
capture the rook you know I'm I'm pretty
much dead bossed anyways so I took and
now Queen c4 Bishop takes e7 Bishop
takes you seven Queen takes e7 and now
you know I was so I was very low on time
by this point but you know I was like
hey wait a second you know maybe I'm
gonna survive this but after Queen takes
checkmate is threatened I have to play
f3 and after Queen e2 I threw in the
towel because there's no way for me to
stop
checkmate from happening you know the
best try would be your f2 but of course
now what does what does white or black
play couple ways to win but yeah Queenie
one I think is fastest if the King comes
up we have checkmate here if there it
comes back
checkmate up here and so I ended up
resigning this game but so yeah that was
like I think the second international
master I ever played and so it was a
crazy game I think and yeah I mean I was
like plus 50 at some point but so I just
couldn't find it couldn't seal the deal
so yeah you know what a start to a
tournament though right and so uh yeah
one of the craziest games of chess I've
ever played
but in the end yeah you got the better
of me
it's tough to put those those ions away
they seem to find ways out of a out of
positions and now I want to show one of
the highest rated players I ever
actually have beaten which was Katarina
nem Silva so let's take a look at this
game it's a little bit less tactical and
crazy you know with wiping down and rook
and trying to trap a queen but you know
still still an interesting game so let's
see yeah all these games happened in the
st. Louis open it was one of the you
know crazies turned into my life you
know beat Katarina lost to Michael
Brooks but in such a crazy fashion and I
think I gained something like 70 rating
points from this tournament on the whole
so definitely never gonna top that again
in my chess career although who knows
maybe this weekend I'll win all my games
it's the bill right this year so this
was the bull ride of 2017 which is why
I'm going over it now because in
preparation for the bill right coming up
so yes so d 4e 6 c4 f5 we're now in a
Dutch g3 night
Bishop g2 c6 Knight f3 and the Stonewall
so the Stonewall doesn't have the
greatest reputation uh you know in in
chess at currently but it's definitely a
very solid opening so you know nothing
to nothing to take lightly so we see
Bishop f4 Bishop e7 castles so this is a
little bit unorthodox usually usually
this Bishop on f4 gets traded off
somehow
usually this Bishop is already on d6 and
kind of trades itself off in this bishop
or you know this Bishop just ed Lee's
contests the other on Bishop d6 even if
it doesn't trade right away but so
Audrina chose to put on e7 which I
didn't fully understand but you know
it's a fine square black castles Knight
c3 Knight h5 threatening this Bishop and
so uh you know I have a few options here
I can play Bishop e5 but in the game I
decided on this pawn structure wouldn't
actually be so horrible right
I keep control over e5 but I also keep
f3 in reserve if I ever need to
challenge this efore square so I just
decided to play e3 which is perfectly
reasonable
we see Knight to d7 Queen e2 Knight to
f6 and I should mention we're actually
still I think in theory here or in known
territory Queen e2 is the first move
where I actually deviated and I think
this is a game where I'm actually
following shear of yes so playing like a
Lexie shear of so far not so bad not so
bad
Queenie to you though wasn't sheriff's
choice so now I'm in novelty territory
never played before
so Knight D to f6 so this was kind of a
weird maneuver but you know Black has to
start doing things like this in the
Stonewall because he just really doesn't
have a lot of space right he's kind of
stuck back here I continued with rook to
be one so you know if you've seen my
lecture on minority attacks and you'll
know they call them in all shapes and
sizes and this is just another another
version of it right I'm just launching
the b-pawn forward trying to make a
weakness on c6 black tries to prevent
this by playing a5 and you know already
actually things are kind of awkward for
black I think I really prefer White's
position here so maybe something had
gone wrong in the opening four for
Katarina I'm not sure where exactly but
maybe some of these weird night
maneuvers weren't weren't so good I just
continued with night a4 so I'm preparing
to play c5 maybe and bring this night in
to b6 where it can cause some some
trouble and now Katarina hit me with the
D takes c4 so this is a move you
actually don't often see in the
Stonewall because it really doesn't a
lot to open up this Bishop scope so you
know you have to be pretty careful if
you're gonna play something like this
but of course she had an idea so I mean
what happens if I just recapture
normally
yeah b5 is a fork and it's not the
simplest fork ever I do get to capture
here but now after Bishop d7 I think I
am he's defending his rook he's
attacking my queen
he's defending his pawn well sorry she
in this case and so I would be losing
peace but you know no need to panic I
don't need to recapture this pawn yeah
so do you have a question I heard
something okay I made that up might be
hearing them all the way over there but
okay Knight c3 and now now I'm preparing
to take this pawn right and so I can
continue with something like 95 you know
opening up this bishop and things are
looking okay for me in the game she
chose Knight to d5 so she got rid of
this good pawn on d5 but it does give
her the advantage of having this square
for pieces I went ahead and played Queen
takes you know what I was planning all
along Bishop d7 I do want to mention
though this would be a huge mistake
trying to hold on to this pawn right
because now this Bishop is really just
too strong I can play something like 95
right away and you know this pawn is
going to fall and this Bishop will
really tell the tale so no way for black
to really hold on to this which is why
we saw 95 so yeah it captures Bishop d7
trying to find a way for this Bishop to
escape I played Bishop e5 finally you
know moving my Bishop out of a capture
Knight f6 Queen back to e2 bishop e8 and
nighty one so what do you think's going
on here who would you rather would you
rather be in this situation
yeah I definitely preferred white it I
was kind of confused how I'd manage to
get such a position um against you know
like Katarina who's obviously very
talented and experienced player but so
you know I I was more than happy with it
right so why is white better let's let's
talk about it yeah it's a lot of this
central space you know black would love
to be able to put a piece on e4 but you
know he just doesn't have control over
that square anymore a lot of that comes
from this pawn capturing on c4
and you know a lot of it comes from this
move which I might not ever really have
to play but it's nice to have it kind of
in reserve to guard this square if I
ever need if I ever really need to the
other thing that you know comes to mind
is with the removal of this deep on this
pawn becomes a lot more week and this
diagonal becomes a lot more weak so it's
it's quite obvious how white wants to
continue here right white wants to just
open up this Queen side put his pieces
on a good squares and just attack some
of these weaknesses whereas for black
it's not so obvious what you want to do
perhaps you want to bring this Bishop
out through age five but then I mean
it's it's just one Bishop right and what
is it really doing over there it's not
really attacking any weaknesses or
anything it might be more active than on
ei
so in the game she did play Bishop h5
Queen d2 and now b5 was her try so
rather than letting me advance on the
Queen side she's advancing herself but
of course you know what does this leave
behind what a huge weakness does she
have to deal with yes
c6 and that's gonna be a problem for
kind of the rest of the game so already
I think white is just kind of winning
because there's really nothing black can
can try to do here to try to unravel you
know it's just this is gonna be a
permanent weakness this is gonna be a
permanent weakness and white really
hasn't made these kind of
this is yet so unless you know black has
super active pieces which she doesn't
it's it's not gonna not gonna be good
not gonna be good
so Knight to d3 the most natural one
making this making sure this square
doesn't fall to a you know blacks hands
she advanced further with b4 which of
course allows Knight a for and now the
square is you know firmly under my
control
so Knight to d7 rook BC one rook c8 and
now I simply double and this position is
you it's kind of the the perfect picture
of what's going on here right I don't
know if I've ever seen so many black
pieces cramps on you know this the back
row here in second row it's kind of
everybody's huddled in the center trying
to you know keep this weakness here
together and this weakness together and
it's quite obvious that you know why it
should be should be winning here I think
in the game she chose to rock f7 which
may be a minor improvement off the back
rank but you know maybe a necessary one
i moved my queen back over to e2 now
this Bishop gave up control I thought
this might be a better square some
options to activate the Queen Bishop f6
Knight c5 occupying this square so of
course this is under threats and it's
not so easy to defend it right
you can't play a rook d7 because of
Bishop d6 I think hopefully this tactic
works and then you can't play Queen e7
or well maybe you can but felt like
something should be wrong here I'm not
sure off the top of my head that's uh
okay this is obviously not what you want
to be doing right in the game you know
that's why she chose to capture and so I
took with the rook because I wanted to
keep this night you know defending this
a five square Bishop back to e7 and just
right back to see to simply and so now
Bishop d7 and you might think black has
made some progress here because she's
made it managed to trade off one of
those pieces but
I think it's it's still kind of beyond
hope and I have easier access now to to
this c6 pawn so what in the game I chose
Knight c5 again just replacing the first
night with the second one Bishop back to
f8 black this is kind of just passing
time here and now e4 is the the critical
move so I've placed all my pieces on the
best squares that they can be on and now
of course I try to open it up when my
opponent has less space when my
opponent's pieces aren't really working
together when you know she's going to be
unprepared to handle and opening up of
the position and that happens a lot in
in games is you have this kind of
spatial advantage but you're not really
sure how to you know continue you know
there's weaknesses here on a5 on c6 on
e6 but so how do you get at them and
this is how you get at them you have to
play moves like efore which really open
the position and now I decided now is
the time to do it so II for F takes
bishop takes and all of a sudden you
know there are threats on the Kings side
there are these threats in the center
there are these threats on the Queen
side and it's gonna be too much for
black to handle so Queen g5 was her
choice
I simply played Knight takes d7 Erik
takes d7 and all of a sudden you know
this pawn has been left behind don't
really want to capture it right away
though maybe I can but I was slightly
concerned about something black can do
here which what do you think that might
be yeah there's there's Queen c1 and
probably white is still winning here but
I thought you know I'm already winning
y-you know I'll out such an imbalance
but you know what I just had highlighted
there was you know the king is gonna be
weak this phone's gonna be weak this
pawn is gonna be weak there should be no
way the rooks can really hold on here
anyways in the game though just to be
safe I chose to play h4 first driving
this Queen off of this square we saw
Queen h6 I played simply king g2 so now
this move you know at least doesn't
check and if she were to capture and c1
eventually Knight back to e7
so she's managed to defend this pawn one
more time but it's it's really not gonna
be enough
I played Queen a six taking advantage
you know when you place your pieces in
the center something nice about it is
they can go to either side when need be
so I decided you know attacking these
pawns that's more important
rook back to d8 and defending and now
this pawn just Falls and here let's see
yeah I played Queen b6 and chose to
capture this Knight probably I should
just start to start taking pawns like
this but so I kind of made it hard on
myself after Queen b6 queen g6 you know
black has made a single threat and
probably what I should have done is just
kind of step out of it either with King
g1 maybe King age 2 I'm just stepping
out of any checks and then and only then
captured on on c6 here but so I kind of
made it hard on myself in the game
because I thought okay I'm up a pawn I'm
not Material time it's time to simplify
but this is kind of something to be
careful of is simplifying too early when
you don't really have enough of an edge
of a winning position yet to kind of
justify it but yeah I tried Bishop takes
f5 queen of five takes and this allows
Queen to e4 and now takes takes take
stakes and all of a sudden all those
pieces are gone and we're in a rook in
game so in my head I thought I had
calculated okay I'm counting the pawns
here I'm up two pawns and I'm gonna win
a third but it's actually not so simple
at all because black has this rook e8
move and now all of a sudden you know
I'm gonna lose this guy might lose this
guy too and sure I'm still getting this
pawn but so it's it's I'm still gonna be
in for a fight now
which is not what you not what I wanted
so definitely that's something to look
out for is when you're converting
positions be careful of simplifying too
early especially if you're not really
risking anything and that goes all the
way back to here simply a king age 2 and
you can't you can't make a move for
black you know it's there's no way to
defend this there's no way to defend
this after the sky falls there's just
nothing black can really do
so would have been much easier if I just
played king h2 instead though you know I
ended up in this end game rook takes c6
or it takes a to d5 we see rook check a
kingi to a rook to d1 only way to defend
this pawn is to push it to d6 but of
course what happens if I try that
something rather unfortunate well now I
have enough defenders yeah King f7 and
my rook is traps can't go back can't go
left can't go right and he can't go up
that's not so good uh say I didn't play
d6 so instead I tried Bishop d6 which I
thought was interesting putting some
pressure on this pawn putting some
pressure here if I'm allowed to play
rook e8 then that would be quite nice
black just responds with takes and I
went in for this endgame so this is a
lot less clear than that first position
we saw right so this is you got to be
super careful especially against these
high grade of plays they find these end
games where it's not so obvious if
you're gonna win or not but okay let's
try and look at what's going what's
going on here obviously White has this
pawn Vantage but you know it's the pawn
on f2 it's not close to queening or
anything it's not even close to being
passed and black has this pawn on b4
which is under fire and it's kind of
tying down this rook on d4 and the last
thing you know I would look at is the
Kings and this is what really spells the
difference here in this end game is is
the Kings so would you rather have
White's King position or blacks King
position yeah white obviously it's the
reason for that is white has a clear
path to kind of get to the center kind
of mess around with this rook and blacks
King is gonna be stuck on this back rank
for a long time there's really no way to
kind of escape
you can yeah that that's another idea Oh
King f3 king of three as well as you
know one idea
but the big thing is gonna be you know
White has a few options but you know
black really can't get this king out you
can try something like h6 or h5 and
running out this way but it's going to
be quite slow right you have to go all
the way around this pawn to get to the
center so that's what told the
difference we saw you know Rick p7 h6
instead of h5 I played b3 here g5 and I
thought that this move was kind of a
mistake although the end game is
probably losing but you know why might
this move be wrong what's wrong with
this
um not exactly
because you know if I don't if I were to
like trade off or something or how do
you think it might result in the past
pawn cuz I don't see it especially if
you know g4 happens yeah that's exactly
right now there's no way for this King
to get off the back rank you just you
can't do it and in addition to that this
pawn on h6 is now going to be weak so
I'm always gonna be threatening a trick
h7 at some moment at the right moment
and then I can take here and push my H
pawn hopefully in a perfect world so of
course in a nun game where you trying to
win do you want to trade ponds or keep
ponds on keep them on you need more
queens more queens more pawns more
queens
so I played h5 avoiding a trade King g8
so stopping this Rick h7 but you know of
course bringing the King even further
away from where he needs to be so now of
course I just try and get the king in
King f3 here would now be a mistake
because of check and takes so I went the
other way
King f1 but black found this this nice
try
rook to e4 cutting this King off and so
now is kind of the moment of truth how
does white ever make progress because if
you do try to come back to g2 and say
now I'm gonna go to f3 since you're not
here anymore
you know black simply repeats so you
need something needs something here
yeah that's actually what I did in the
game so you can attack this rook with f3
if the rook comes this way now we get
our King in the game and the more
complicated one is what if the rook III
what do you want to do here
yeah you take the b-pawn you lose this
pawn with check but now we have a passed
pawn and it's quite far away from where
blacks King is going to be and our King
actually vs kind of important still has
a path into the game so this is actually
dead lost for black now and this is the
what happened in the game I think so
King h3 trying to get the King in some
moves were played and now what's the
best way to kind of advance for white I
think a lot of things are winning here
but one way is it's quite quite easy
it's kind of tough to win with the rook
stuck in front of the pawn right but
there's an improvement to be made
oh yeah sure King f5 but then maybe
let's see maybe we just start checking
you can get all the way over here then
you want to go up maybe but once you
start doing stuff like this I'll grab
this pawn maybe and then I try and come
back defends which you know it's not
perfect but white might be winning after
king of five actually just gave away the
move that's my bed but yes so King f5
might be winning but so first first
things first I wanted to have the
perfect world where I keep pressure on
this pawn keep this pawn defended and
actually be threatening to take this
pawn rather than giving up my pawn so I
gave this check and played b6 so a few
advantages now my pawns one square
further one square closer my group can
defend this pawn and attack this pawn
and this King is entombed so yes just
simply rook g6 check it's all it's all
you needed and so you know this is this
is over now the game continued check
check g4 and of course you know no need
to worry about this pawn because this
gun this one is gonna tell the tale
brought the king over brought the king
up and I don't know where she might have
resigned here she might have resent a
couple moves earlier but I mean that the
rest was was fairly easy so yeah that
was another you know crazy game one of
the highest-rated players i've i've ever
taken down and a little story about this
this game which i don't know how happy
she'd be with me sharing this story but
the weekend before the bill right st.
louis open catarina was actually our GM
and residents here at the club and you
know me being a you know it's it's a
couple years ago i'm still a big chess
enthusiasts when i get better when i
improve so i think okay maybe I'll take
a lesson with the geuman residents here
at the st. louis chess club so the
weekend before the tournament i had
actually taken a lesson with Katerina
and then
lo and behold the tournament comes I get
paired with her and things go my way so
you must have been the best lesson of my
life it's what I always say she's just
such a great teacher that she passed on
all of her wisdom
Oliver experienced and managed to help
me out in the game but yes so that's all
we actually have time for only two games
we got over tonight but definitely
complicated ones a lot to go over a few
takeaways takeaway from this game is
definitely be careful simplifying too
early and you know when you're when you
have that positional edge when your
pieces are better you want to open up
that position that's how you really can
start to convert you know with that
being said thanks for joining me here
tonight as always this has been the road
to mm and I'll see you guys next week
all right
you
[Music]